now you're ahead of presents capture it
was all right okay in based in the bay
area right bays in sunnyvale yes okay
and what exactly does your department do
in terms of making this beautiful piece
of machinery right now so presents
capture and the name of it is really
focusing on their reality part of
virtual reality so of course you have a
lot of words generated by computers that
can take you anywhere in fantasy world
but we're looking at the reality aspect
so what we focus on is to create devices
that could be in a capture area or in
other areas of the ecosystem in order to
recreate reality so that you can be
either tele transported or even travel
in time only towards the past not to the
future but you can go back and revisit
situation that you were part of but look
around and look in different direction
than the one that you choose when you
were there
you